well everybody and welcome to part 17 of
our intermediate Python series as well
as another part in the object-oriented
programming
mini-series so in this tutorial we're
going to be talking about inheritance
and inheritance is a major player in
modularity but it also can help a lot
with actually scaling and
maintainability over time mostly because
the notion of inheritance helps us to
not add too much clutter to our code as
in that also just not having that
clutter also will help us scale over
time and all that and then also just in
terms of modularity it allows other
people to take what we've got so far and
then kind of mold it a little bit more
to what they need so with
object-oriented programming just because
you're being taught object-oriented
programming here I don't expect everyone
to go out and all the code that they
write now is gonna be object-oriented
right that doesn't really make much
sense but when you are doing something
like making something maybe for a client
or maybe you're you have like some sort
of open source software that people are
using I mean all of pretty much all the
libraries that you're gonna be using
there are object-oriented because it
just makes sense for them to be
object-oriented when that are going to
be used by other people so one thing and
of frame of mind to always be in when
you're writing classes is this kind of
like let's do the the Minimum Viable
Product which I mean is obviously kind
of like business lingo for truly the the
most simplest form of the product that
we can come up with but it's a good
thing to always have plus it's actually
fairly realistic because again you're
usually gonna be writing object-oriented
programming when you're actually trying
to deliver something to a client to
somebody a customer who is requesting
something right so it's always a good
idea to just try to keep things as
simple as possible and that's where
inheritance can come into play too and
so maybe in this case you're actually
more playing the user where we're gonna
actually use a class and inherit that
class but then also make some changes to
it so with that let's go ahead and hop
into it so at this point we're importing
blob and then we're just straight using
blob and it's giving us our
blobs as we might expect so now what
we're gonna do is actually we're going
to create a new blob class and we're
just gonna say class blue blob and it's
going to inherit from blob okay so do
inherit we just passed the some other
class in there so this is your parent
class
it's your superclass okay these are
names you're gonna hear people
interchange these names you might even
also hear it called a base class
so all these three names you're gonna
hear and it's just other people from
other languages bringing their
terminology to Python really they're
basically all the same but I wouldn't on
it suggest that you go to another
language and you call them all the same
thing anyway yeah so parent base class
and super ok all the same so we're
inheriting from blob and we can actually
just pass here but what we can do is
take blue blob now copy that and then
we're going to come down and replace and
replace right so now we're gonna run
this okay we got the same thing as we
got before but it's just showing you at
least that in its most simplest form
we're just we're creating a new class
and we're inheriting from this base
class blob and we're getting everything
so when you inherit from another class
you're inheriting everything all of the
methods and all that is coming to this
new class now probably one of the first
things that people are going to want to
do is maybe change some things but
probably the first thing that's going to
come up is to modify the the init method
so for example you might have a scenario
where with blue blob blob
you're just you're gonna say okay well
when this is called you know maybe we
want to make the color blue this is a
blue blob class therefore maybe what
we're gonna think of doing is like
define and then we'll do the dunder init
pass self and then self dot color is W
equals blue or something like that
you might think okay yeah let's do that
well when we run that we get a big old
honkin error basically that it's it's
supposed to take one argument but we got
four well that's because down here when
we call blue blob we're passing so and
then also we're passing blue width and
height
so what's going on there so how could we
have an init method for both classes
well that's where super comes into play
and so instead what we can do is we can
say something like this we can say super
and then dots underscore underscore in
it so we're just basically we're running
the init method for the superclass
whatever that superclass might be and
we're gonna say color X boundary and Y
boundary and then of course because
we're doing that this is all now this is
all contained within our init method
we're using these parameters here so we
need to pass them as well and that's
space there and for now I'm just gonna
do well we can leave blue there that
should be fine so now everything's gonna
be blue though so where we say red blobs
it it's going to actually change them to
blue so let's go ahead and run that and
now sure enough all we have are blue
blobs but that's how we can reference
that base class that parent class and
this class is your child class or your
subclass again you're gonna hear both
terms it's the same thing child class
subclass it's the same thing in Python
at least in this setting so the only
other thing that people might be
uncomfortable with is the use of super
here it's you could get away with doing
something like we could say here we
could say blob dot in it and then we
have to we have to pass the instance so
we would say self because like in that
we use suit when you're using super you
don't have to pass self but in this case
you do right we're actually missing one
positional argument because this was
being passed itself but if we pass self
here this will work and sure enough it
works but now it's it's it's a form of
hard coding and in this case it's not a
big deal but at some point you're gonna
come across a time when you want to
engage in what's called multiple
inheritance and this is going to cause a
whole lot of problems so so we use super
init and we don't have the self there
there is a fantastic talk by raymond
head injure pulsar
check it out all I remember I'll put a
link in description but there's already
a link in the text-based version of this
tutorial so definitely check out the
talk it's kind of long if you're not
familiar with Raymond he is a great
speaker though so definitely worth
checking out so anyway if you want to
learn more about super and get a little
more comfortable with how it works
especially if you're coming from another
language where maybe you got your idea
of how super works that's not
necessarily gonna be the case here so
anyway that's all our we're gonna do is
super for now maybe later we'll get into
the more interesting details of super
but that's all we're gonna do for now
now when it comes to inheritance the
other thing that we can do is actually
add new methods right so in this case
we've got just this one you know init
method we're just trying we're just
changing the the color of the blob and
we're basically rewriting the init
method so in so a good thing to keep in
mind is first of all we can inherit and
when we inherit we're taking all of the
methods from the parent class we can
overwrite those methods as we've done
here we over wrote the init method so
because there's two methods when we
inherited from the blob class when we
did this we're basically overriding that
init method that's why it didn't work
when we had to init methods and we
weren't calling super or we weren't
calling blob dot in it we didn't have
the required code basically to run what
we needed so we could we could also
rewrite move like we have a move method
but instead what we're gonna do is
actually we're gonna create a new method
and we're gonna say move fast and this
method only needs to take so and then
what we're gonna say is self dot x
equals something and self dot y equals
something and let me see if we got
random we do have random so move fast
will just be random
and range negative 7 to positive 7 paste
and now we can use this new move fast
method somewhere here we go
blob move now let's blob down move fast
so now we're gonna have some fast moves
and blobs oh they've all gone to the
corner did we not do a negative negative
7 to 7 why did they all go
what am I missing o equals ah plus
equals there we go let's try again
there we go so some really fast very
definitely jaggedy not very smooth
moving blobs but they are fast
that's anyway that's how you can add new
methods to basically you're just you're
kind of just adding on top or molding
the blob class we could overwrite things
we can change things and we can even run
specific methods if we need to for
whatever reason in most cases that's
going to be something like your init
method but there you can do a lot of
pretty cool things with super so again
check out that talk by Raymond I
probably won't talk too much about that
he is gonna explain it way better than I
can he does live examples it's basically
the same thing so anyway he's a lot
smarter though so that's it for this
tutorial if you have any questions
comments concerns anything else leave it
below otherwise I will see you in the
next tutorial